I'm gonna check that one out but first
of all I am delighted to be joined by
mr. Michael McBain from Xavier well my
favorite interviews from III know thank
you for the Creator my favorite
interviews it was a really yes okay
let's try do it again at Chris waters
and Kevin vine over here as well of
course we're gonna we're gonna make it
the best interview ever for Lynch them
battle mage or as Chris and the rest of
our colleagues like to call it list um
battle homage
this is this game it's out today it is
like officially officially out no more
beta play the whole thing and how does
that feel you guys been working on this
for quite a while yeah it's a big deal
we're all kind of freaking out a little
bit and before we talk about the game I
want to briefly touch on kind of your
story because I that's what we talked
right before you three abettors cracked
like how many games you've worked on I
assumed that you'd worked on a bunch of
games because this is this seems to be a
game that's quite mechanically deep and
whatnot
but this is your first game this is
David's first game where that is correct
yes it's her first game for the studio
and the first game for me as well so you
used to work in a totally different
industry and then kind of decided you
wanted to make a game about badass mages
yeah I mean we were in a position where
I had an engineering team that I could
kind of do whatever I wanted and I said
well I've always I'm an avid gamer I
always want to play games so I'm gonna
make one what's is what we did well it's
not like a daunting experience like
coming from it was to be honest it was a
little sobering I think the beginning
you know it we knew that we needed to
get some experts headed ship games
before but but it was a there was
definitely a labor of love involved in
this at you know we took us a while to
get going and figure out what we were
gonna do we spent some time prototyping
and started on this about two years ago
and this is our our first thing and we
feel good about it
fantastic we're all excited let's hop
right in Kevin you've won a bunch of
times on the on the lobby
I've been on the lobby before playing
the game and I'm gonna be sure I'll be
terrible it's yes it's it's just the
given the developers here so this means
I'm gonna look as bad as possible
your attitude is terrible it's it's the
thing I do come on you know you got this
luckily I don't need the health the
shield so I'm just gonna go right I
believe in you there first of all this
is obviously I think this game makes a
really great first impression it looks
gorgeous
this is cry-cry engine right yes it is
that's correct and this is actually a
very fairly tough area to get through
right Kevin always picks the toughest
areas so what are these gross blocks
that you're making oh you got it's my
least favorite thing to happen that's
that
ballin voltar he's probably gonna shoot
you again while you stare at that so
it's about mage is a first-person game
where you play as a mage but you guys
kind of I guess because you're only
playing is made you not like doubling up
and I mean anyone else the mages role
within battle is kind of has changed you
guys have gotten rid of cooldowns and
whatnot that's correct you know we just
wanted to do something that really
highlights magic and we started by
taking away some of the you know the
things that typically get constraints
that are put on magic writing where
you've got cooldowns and mana bars and
things and just make it all about just
throwing your power around as much as
you can and I'm sneaking already but
this is a particularly tough area I have
to say got your corruption going now
that's that's cool I really love
corruption it's my favorite thing
because oh god damn generally gosh yeah
the neat thing about corruption is it's
about opening your enemy with parasites
and so depending on how you build your
your spell there's three different ways
to build every spell you've got
destruction which is about doing damage
or control which is typically about you
know crowd controlling an enemy and then
you've got mastery which is about D
buffing them so you get really huge big
crits on them I gotta say I love that
getting frozen screen yeah it's not like
all the edges of my vision are blue like
no your eyeballs straight up frozen over
you can't see crap and this gym is a
from my experience playing it and also
from watching Kevin suck real hard on
the lobby it's a challenging
first-person game always surprisingly
challenging I just sorry I didn't mean
to interrupt it I wasn't really
expecting the challenge that it became
and whatever minded folks I don't have
to have any questions for hopefully for
Michael because I feel like Kevin's got
is that he's busy enough here yeah by
all means put them in the twist shot
I'll be I'll be pulled them pulling them
out of there
so that guy is the guy that was freezing
you primarily when you see those bomb
filters with that blue mm-hmm that means
it their shots are frozen shots and we
talked a little bit about the the sort
of
spell creation tool case because I found
this really interesting at e3 yeah
instead of there being like straight-up
just a bunch of trees that you kind of
pulled prom and poor experience into you
guys that went a little bit deeper on
your spell creation yeah what we did is
we made it so that instead of dropping
spells that are pre-made or upgrades
that are pre-made it's all about
dropping the components all could you
want this to build your own spells right
to build on the weight that you want to
build them so you've got the basic shape
of the spell which is determines how
you're going to deliver it right like
this is like a bowl this is a what we
call a missile spell so it actually has
a little bit of a homing and and then
there's other different targeted shapes
like a lob that has no aiming component
throws us a lob and breaks into other
things yes and then there's a beam
there's a couple of different a OES and
so forth so you take that shape and then
you take these other components that are
called augments that come in the form of
destruction control and mastery and
those determine how your spell is going
to behave that must have been crazy for
you guys to sort of bug test because
presumably is quite a lot of variation
that can happen yes yeah there is quite
a number of different different things
because there's eight sigils in the game
and there's seven different ways to
shape them and then you've got three
different ways to build each shape so it
can get out of hand I got a first
question here from Hassan and jasmine is
there a story in this game there is we
have a story you basically are playing
an individual who the sort of nobility
the dark nobility of the town has put
them under your boot and you become
freed by some an older mage that gives
you these bracers of power to let you
exact revenge and then kind of fight for
the good of the city so you guys went in
went pretty deep but voice acting as
well as we did yeah we have Troy Baker
and Jennifer Hale and Clancy Brown and
and some others is that presumably a lot
of the stuff that people who has on the
early access because this has been in I
guess Alton well beta presumably mostly
for quite a while now and is that mostly
what's comment in the full release the
sort of the story is now one straight
yes yeah now that we have the whole
story in there we've had bits and pieces
that have come online as we as we came
online with our different stages of the
game
and we've got we've added quite a bit of
depth to that to the story so shall we
do I thought I'd show the yes a bit so
one one good place to start obviously a
synthesis because you can take you keep
upgrading these things like you start
with just like white white things and
you you gradually combine those and they
become more powerful then you start
combining those are the become more
powerful and there's a there's a certain
element where it's like hmm I wonder
what this is going to make when I press
all together and so we can start with
something like like just combining these
three are you expecting then now we have
a dissolving destruction of precision
it's hard to read the TV but like so
then you get multipliers and and and yes
you get increased apocalyptical is there
that's pretty cool let go if you look at
the synthesis if you go up to one of the
blue ones you have there oh you'll see
that there's go down one two that
hardened shield the one layer here oh
here that that there's two there's
actually two synthesis options on that
so you can synthesize that from purple
to orange so you can go up twice on that
one
have you had your community sort of
almost having like like a cookbook
battles where they were creating like
different spells and sharing them with
in the yes there's one not right have
you considered a sequels with a game
called cookbook battles this is why I
don't make video games and hgp one is
asking about the story em is it linear
is it open loops and how long does it
look like though so the approach that we
took to the level design is it's they're
tailored levels you have a beginning and
an end to each level that you go through
they're they're crafted in that sense
some of the later levels have some more
exploration areas where they kind of
open up and you have different paths
that you can take but it's it's a we
have a sort of a beginning to end
approach to this yeah are you guys gonna
be adding more to it over the next
coming months and years is this a we
have a net where I haven't announced any
upcoming stuff yet but we're definitely
not done to be a little bit fun funny to
spend so much time engaging with your
community and adding stuff and it
happily just to cut it off exactly
that's been a big thing for us just the
the early access has been phenomenal for
us it really helped own the game
this is a completely different game just
12 weeks ago really yes it looked very
very different better than do you
imagine that will continue to be the
case
last week and one of them mhm how do you
choose what time to release it so we had
decided that we knew that two years ago
yeah when we sat down we we had this
date set o based on the dates as opposed
to yeah we were shooting for the date
because you know when you go to release
a game it's we don't have a publisher
right this is this is just something
that we're doing on our own and it's
easy to just keep going forever yeah you
have to pick a date and then and release
it so that's what we did is that
something you've taken from your as an
x-block yeah it's not a sort of a
mentality you've taken from your your
previous job of applying it's yes you
have to have enough have a constraint
that we have current king of the Dead 91
ask can you customize your gear so
outside of the spell stuff in terms of
items and whatnot or is that more of a
warrior game thing yeah that so for us
it's all about your magic and then eight
power so everything that's dropping is
your spell's in your defense there are
no bracers or stabs or robes or anything
like that it's all in your magic a lot
of questions in the chat asking I'm
gonna go up up Jones 1980 at what
platform this is on so this is that on
Steam today on PC that's correct and you
guys look enough consoles at all for
this bad boy so you know I'd love to see
this on a console we don't have any
specific plans for that yet but I would
definitely love to see what this base
obama Don's asks great name and those
are multiplayer any co-op any
competitive no right now it's a
single-player experience we're going to
coin your I hate them down here do it do
it take it take it do it quick ego Kevin
talk a little bit about how you're sort
of what what your tactics here on combat
is so it depends on what I'm facing
sometimes there's just there's just a
good old-fashioned you know like serious
Sam move backwards and and do your best
but that doesn't always work and
sometimes blocking is the better thing
even for me when I'm not as block heavy
as I think the game wants me to be nice
now his eyeballs are frozen as you see
like right now I'm a little worried
about stuff like that so oh I thought I
was dead been going one thing that I
like though is that
you get to you get to keep everything so
so death is basically just uh you know
go back to the previous point um but you
get to keep all of the things that you
got sort of using trouble and he said
ice levelled up during that section so
those those levels up they stay with you
that's correct
oh yeah yes everything so you not only
the loot every time will answer your
inventory hmm you get it saves the game
and then oh cool and then you your your
sigils level as you're doing things they
have different requirements so it might
be killed a certain number of enemies or
that sort of thing
I just zoomed right through this bit
before it's funny that I specifically
didn't take another route because
there's another route they're really
hard I'm not gonna do that I'll look
like a fool we're obviously looking at
the sort of Arctic tundra level here and
there's a lot of variety as well in
terms of levels that is correct right
when you get later in the game there's
you know there's a swimmer area there's
a desert area sort of a ruins in the
desert that's really really cool you can
see all that sort of stuff on em gang
spot zone coverage and also I know on
the steam page on the store page you've
got a little trailer there as well that
people could check that at groups you're
right ass is there a limit to the number
of spells you can create like a max
level or is it more based on you
discovering the sigils and the yeah so
we are our loot drops in tiers and as
you go through the game that tier
continually increases and we go pretty
deep in the tiers in our new game plus
we have a new game + experience that
after you complete the story we kind of
chain pieces together ok so you do these
little different types of missions as
you go through facing different types of
enemies do you expect people to to do
that to sort of take the character that
they'd had or do you think people will
sort of start them to start and respec
so we really kind of have you know the
an option to do both if you want to
start over again and play something you
haven't played you can do that you have
access to all the sigils but the way the
leveling works you can only level 3 of
them okay so if you decide to level a
fourth you have to turn one of the other
three oh and you lose all your levels
okay so so there's a choice to make
is there any add - - respecting like -
do you lose any of your XP when you
respect or yes it's nice move around
yeah it's it's all based on tasks
are like kill 30 enemies kill 80 enemies
so you lose that progress and you have
to go through that again if you decide
to switch let's upgrade the sigil my
favorite thing about doing these I saw
this coming
I saw his coming the good news is that
whatever yeah the good news is that most
of I don't know I don't know like I I'm
actually starting to sort of enjoy this
this challenge because I like having to
learn new ways of dealing with it the
the first boss it was interesting like
the first the first point where it was
where it really was hard for me is the
very first boss and it took a little bit
of doing because it's one of those
bosses where it's just not like okay
you're not just dealing with big dude
you're dealing with a bunch of adds to
minions you just come from playing quite
a lot of divinity so it's almost like I
did that's that's all kind of hard but
one of my favorite things about doing a
game where people are interested in it
is that the questions coming through her
so specific I'm gonna go real quick
one-word answers on this sockitumi ask
any pet system pet system yes okay any
puzzles like side quests outside of the
main combat not slender no any is there
a lava level a lava level yeah there's
lava in a level yes great okay
technically like it watch out for the
moment Kevin oh I always forget about
the bowmen thank you there's and there's
two of them I feel I think I got the one
though excellence all right Kevin you
kill this dude or die I thought I was
almost there people if you got a bug
mark I use trolls and they get a pop
with your fire I tell you what to do oh
the number one expert on michdan
bathroom is sitting right beside you
whole thing there as soon as you kill
him it's really like I never like there
was a while
if I go through that other area I'll
swear I'm sorry yeah I got so excited
I'm spitting all over the developer yeah
if I go through the other I will start
swearing because I'm not like trying
right I like using freedom of movement
yeah well I play it and it's it's a
little bit more confined so yes he's
very careful like you get three guys
coming on you at once and you have to
kind of get in in in position so that
you can see all three of them at one
time because if you don't maneuver right
you've got dudes you can't see attacking
you that never goes well in this game
are you doing interview yeah I'm going
on and let me up yeah I don't know
because I don't know how long it's gonna
be but I'm told it's it's quite a bit
longer than where I'm at yes I hope you
got a bit to go through so but I've I'm
enjoying it so far
I enjoyed it in alpha and beta and it's
it's really good to get back to and
there's been a lot done I mean he's
right I mean just from my perspective
like that there's a lot of stuff that's
difference between night and day like
this whole interface all new like all of
that is different just from the last
time I played it so so yes review soon
on gamespot.com
welcome thank you so much you very much
coming in and you guys have come over
obviously all the way from Georgia to
the west coast but you're not just
staying here you're heading up the PAC's
yeah we're in a packs we have a big
booth there so you come by see SFX
excellent listen battle mage out today